so much going on in the world of the NBA
the playoffs but I feel like the most
noise coming out of the playoffs our
team that's not enough if we're joined
out in studio by Tanja Ganguly the LA
Times beat reporter for the LA Lakers
and also my former B reporter when I was
at the Jacksonville yes New Year's right
before the lockout but you know Tonya
you've now covered the Lakers now just
finish your third season going on year
for first of all when you first took
this job did you expect it to be this
much I once they call it chaos but this
much news coming out every single day no
I don't think anyone did I asked them
one the other days it's how it's always
been and they're like no like this is
they used to be a team that no matter
what the drama was in the offseason they
would win right and so that's what's
really different about this team and
that's part of why all this drama is
happening because if the Lakers were
winning and they were in the playoffs
there would be a level of insulation for
them and that's just not there right now
because everyone is very concerned about
when this team is gonna get back to
being the Lakers again well yeah there's
six straight seasons of no playoffs
right and then all the news I suppose
have been coming out whether it's
obviously the Magic Johnson news of
stepping down right before the season
ended and then we've been waiting to
hear from the Los Angeles Lakers whoever
that may be
whether it's Jeanie buss who's the owner
or the general manager and Rob polenka
we wanted answers and so this Saturday
as I was still in mourning from my
warriors losing to the Rockets on last
Saturday yeah there was the shop on HBO
and LeBron James was gonna have his kind
of first comments about the situation
with magic I know the people at HVL
contacted you is something that you need
to watch what did you think first of
LeBron basically telling us kind of what
kind of transpired with magic Johnson
stepping down yeah he was a lot he was
very he seemed hurt it almost seemed
like he felt betrayed by how that went
down because this happen they filmed
this episode on April 11 so it was just
two days after
magic had done this and Matt it didn't
talk to anyone in the locker room when
he did it he talked to us he did a press
conference for about 30 45 minutes and
then he started to walk out of the
building and we all I caught up with him
again after that and and had some
follow-up questions but then he walked
out of the building so he never took
time to tell LeBron and that I think was
what LeBrons you know what LeBron was
saying on the shop is he was like he
didn't even call to say like I'm out
like you know kiss my butt I'm out you
know it's like he didn't he didn't even
do that and it seemed like that really
bothered LeBron at least two days after
it happened
LA Times Lakers beat reporter tongue
again coolly joining the Rich Eisen show
Kirk Morrison here filling in for rich
but you know Talia we've just been
waiting for someone within the Lakers
organization to speak up like tell us
what's going I know it's frustrating for
fans and analysts like myself but you
follow this team you cover this team I
know you've got questions but who's
supposed to be answering these questions
for what's going on in Laker land yeah
you know I I am able to get answers
through sources and through people who
are willing to speak anonymously but
you're right they haven't really come
forward somebody in the organization
hasn't come forward and said it's going
to be Rob pálinka he's going to be
running the front office this is what
the plan is going forward and I think at
a time when there's so much instability
they really needed that so first it was
with Juwan Howard possibly Jason Kidd
and the Monty Williams was the big name
that the Lakers gave a second interview
to and then obviously tyloo and we
understand the connections between tyloo
former Laker obviously coached the Bron
to a championship in Cleveland but to
get that news yesterday no Tanya that
these two just walked away from the
table like it was disrespectful of an
offer that tyloo felt that he received
from the Lakers like where do the Lakers
go from here right now in their coaching
search yeah it was really weird
yesterday because I think right before I
got the call that the Lakers were moving
on I had also heard that ty had was just
kind of throwing up his hands with the
but that he also expected that a deal
would happen so I think there were a lot
of really surprised
people Lakers are interviewing Frank
Vogel today they're probably going to be
interviewing Mike Woodson tomorrow or
maybe in the end of the weekend and then
they're also interested in Lionel
Hollins and they've they're still
thinking about Jason Kidd and Juwan
Howard Jason Kidd wasn't really that
serious of a candidate going in but it
sounds like he impressed them in his
interview and that they're really giving
him a second thought but my big thing is
money wins got the second interview
right ty lue got the second view did the
Lakers not offer the job to money
Williams or Dumont
so Monty Williams basically just walked
away and just took the Phoenix Suns out
without even waiting for a Lakers offer
well they'd yeah they hadn't
communicated with him or tyloo at that
point and once he took the job with the
Phoenix Suns then they were like okay
now we can't now now let's move toward I
mean what we had heard was that they
were always planning ty was always the
ahead of Monty in their in their
estimation but they just they hadn't you
know it's it it was it's been a very
slow and deliberate process and what I
keep being told is that was always the
plan they didn't want to rush into
anything from a PR standpoint if they
don't want it to seem like they're
rushing into tyloo then maybe it makes
sense to wait until Monty gets a
different job I don't I mean it's all
moot at this point Ty's obviously not
gonna be there coach you can follow her
on Twitter at Tanya Ganguly the LA Times
beat reporter for the Los Angeles Lakers
in studio here on the Rich Eisen show
Kirk Morrison filling in for rich but
Talia that's two guys now that kind of
have walked away from the Lakers like is
this not the job that a lot of people in
Laker land or within that Lakers
organization still feel is a prized job
in all of the NBA well I I mean I don't
I I think that it's definitely lost a
little bit of its shine in some ways but
the interesting thing about the tyloo
situation is that Lou was really excited
about this like he you know he played
for the started his career with the
Lakers like he wanted to do this and and
the process I think I think by the end
of it he was like perfectly happy to
move on and and from the Lakers
perspective they also felt like as they
were talking to him I mean there's a
reason that they wouldn't go up from
three
to five years he wanted a five-year
contract they're only offering three and
the money wasn't really right and they
just they didn't feel like he was the
long-term solution so if you're looking
for someone that's gonna be your coach
even beyond LeBron James from their
perspective that's what they didn't feel
like they had that here and so I think
you know it was it broke down from that
from both sides in that way with your
NFL background yeah you've you know been
a part of situations and following and
covering teams that a head coach is
hired but he's also bringing this
offensive coordinator or this defensive
coordinator when you think of the Lakers
job what do you take from hearing that
candidates are being forced to have lead
assistants in which the Lakers
organization is saying you have to have
whether it's Jason Kidd as your lead
assistant or Vogel has to be your lead
assistant it seems like the Lakers are
good from what I'm hearing our forcing
assistance on whoever the coach may be
that was one of the problems I mean it
wasn't I think that it was a little
overstated that it was the Lakers wanted
Jason Kidd and tied didn't and that's
that's what caused the breakdown because
the contract was a big deal too but that
was part of the problem I mean I have
heard that before and I've ever then the
NFL recovered a few coaching searches
like in the NFL and I remember when Bill
O'Brien was hired by the Texans they
there were it took a little while for
that deal to get done and part of that
was that the Texans were interested in
in what his staff would look like and
they had some suggestions and ultimately
they let bill make the decision himself
so I think that that you know there's in
most negotiations there's a flexibility
there's okay we really want you as the
coach and so we're going to give we're
going to give a little here give it
doesn't sound like that is what happened
here that the Lakers weren't thinking
okay we're gonna give a little and make
sure we get tyloo they were pretty they
stuck firm with some of the things that
they that they wanted to see LA Times
Lakers beat writer Tanya Ganguly joining
the Rich Eisen show and so ty lue is out
now okay so what's next for LeBron
because there were the reports that
LeBron is upset at what's going on in
the way that the structure I guess the
power structure in the Lakers
organization is
he doesn't really trust their plan going
forward so what does that do for the new
head coach because obviously if it's not
tyloo is each truly a LeBron guy if it's
not a Juwan Howard or now Monty Williams
who had Laker for LeBron connections is
it like a lose-lose for the next head
coach it doesn't have to be and I think
that that's something that like LeBron
and the next coach are going to have to
get together and be on the same page
about but one of the if you remember on
the shop one of the things that he
talked about was that he came here after
a conversation with magic and the plan
was that they were gonna do this
together and they were gonna return the
Lakers to Showtime together and then
imagine and that was part of why I got
this sense of him feeling betrayed by by
what happened there so I mean I'm sure
it's you know LeBron is probably doing a
lot of thinking about like how he's
going to proceed because in order to I
mean these are the LAT this is the last
stretch of his career and I'm not saying
that once the Lakers contract is over
he's done but it's the last stretch of
his career so how is he going to make
the most of it I think is it's probably
on his mind right now but the new head
coach is going to obviously have Ron
James to coach and but he's also going
to inherit the young players as well
Brandon Ingram Kyle Kuzma Josh Hart but
even the most famous of them all I think
is Lonzo bald I know you wrote about
ronzo from his episode I mean his
appearance on LeBron shop
what do we expect now from a guy like
Alonzo I don't we focus on LeBron but
what about a guy like Lonzo who's had a
lot gone this whole season as well yeah
not just this offseason it's been during
the season I mean we wrote a story a few
a few weeks ago where the FBI has been
investigating his the bit the business
partner that was in with his family
they've been investigating him for
months and so for Lonzo I I wonder if
this is gonna help him to sort of have
other people dealing with that stuff to
have himself removed
you know his he's suing this man saying
that he he mishandled his funds and took
took about two million dollars from him
and you know to he's sort of trying to
extricate himself from this man that his
father trusted so much and from really
his father's influence as much he's
trying to sort of take
roll of his own future a little bit and
you know that stuff absolutely affects I
mean you know like when stuff is going
on your personal life it's these guys
are human like it's hard to not let it
have any impact on what you're doing
professionally so I'm interested to see
like how it how it affects lanza going
forward you know being a former
professional athlete in the NFL always
knew that when free agency came you want
to go to an organization that seems
stable that seems that is going to help
my career
the Lakers going to this free agency
period right now and I'm not so sure I
feel confident if I was an NBA free
agent to walk into that Lakers
organization and feel like they've got a
plan in place for the betterment of my
career there's names that are being
floated enough this guy could join
unless this guy can join the Lakers but
how does this hurt free agency when you
look at the structure of the Los Angeles
Lakers organization yeah I do think
they're gonna have to they're gonna have
to convince free agents that they have
the Lakers for the past several years
it's been like this I mean they have
been struggling to get free agents to
trust them for years now you think all
the way back to LaMarcus Aldridge wasn't
interested Kevin Durant didn't even take
a meeting with them and that's what was
supposed well and that's what was
supposed to change and I remember you
know I talked to I talked to somebody in
the organization after about the this
past summers for agency and when Paul
George didn't didn't talk to them there
was a feeling of like is this still
happening and is this gonna happen again
and then LeBron came and everything was
fine
or so they thought so yeah I think that
but you know that's the thing if they
can get let's say they can get Kawhi
Leonard and suddenly they're again back
in position they've got two stars
they're back in position to be a really
good team and everything could change if
they win everything changes about the
narrative it doesn't matter as much that
there is there was drama in the
offseason but they have to start winning
LA Times Lakers B writer Tong anguli
joining the Rich Eisen show for a couple
more minutes and you know Tonya the one
thing is that Magic Johnson walked
from the president of basketball
operations now we know that the general
manager is still in place in rah polenka
Ginny bus is still the owner but we're
hearing that Lynda Rambis and Kurt
Rambis they're almost running the team
on a day-to-day like what is the Lakers
structure right now in your opinion
that's it that's a complicated question
answer I think because so first of all
Magic Johnson stepped down from his
official role well he's still in contact
with Jeannie she still listens to him
they had dinner last week and Jeannie
sort of played with it and put the
breaking news like tag on her she posted
a photo of them and put breaking news on
it to make fun of the fact that everyone
was gonna go nuts when they saw them
together but they are still talking and
she still very much trusts him so I
think Jeannie's style of management is
that she listens to the people that she
trusts and people that are close to her
Linda's been somebody that's been with
the organization for years and has been
close to Jeannie for decades so that's I
mean the fact that she has a lot of
power right now is not not that
surprising and I think that it's you
know they are letting Rob polenka run
the search he is he's sort of the
official head of the coaching search so
but I you know there aren't a lot of
defined roles in terms of who's doing
what and that's part of what you were
talking about earlier why somebody needs
to come out and talk about it last
question for you
in the NFL which you've covered as well
the owner sometimes just hires guys hey
you're you take over this part I'll keep
my hands away from it you handle the
football side of it is Jeanie buss you
think right now hiring too many friends
and just not hiring a basketball guy to
just say handle it take care of it I'm
gonna stay out of it
well you know I think that that's what
she was trying to do when she had when
she hired magic and when she put hired
Rob pálinka what she was trying to do is
to say you guys handle the basketball
I'm just gonna let you handle it um you
know it's it's again hard to answer
without knowing exactly exactly what's
going on in there who is who she's truly
listening to right now but
she has she has generally I mean she's
been the business face of the Lakers for
years her dad trusted her to be the
controlling owner of the team and I
think her plan for since she'd started
doing that was to allow other people to
handle the basketball side of things so
it'll be interesting to see how she
handles that going forward very
interesting to see as the it's been a
soap opera the reality show right in
front of us as the Lakers turn is that
we can call it right tell you thank you
so much I appreciate you that's Tanya
Ganguly the LA Times Lakers beat writer
you can also follow her on Twitter at
Tanya Ganguly thanks again Tanya for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app